hi I'm Greg hi Valon a partner at aura
Carrington and Sutcliff in the emerging
companies here in Silicon Valley charm
sheets is my life and if you ask my wife
that's it that's all I do but I have the
pleasure today to have two fantastic
co-panelists who I sat in the middle I
should have let them sit next to each
other because the best kind of Moktar
machine negotiation is where the
panelists actually kind of get at each
other's throats
I think based upon a call we had but a
recession call there's the possibility
some violence here there's there's some
strong feelings so I will allow Ken
elephant and farm media to introduce
themselves okay hi I'm Ken elephant I'm
a general partner at opus capital we've
been investing in startups for about 35
years we used to be called white spec
and Greer Venture Partners we focus on
early stage investment so ideally
series-a investments like this term
sheet is here and we invest only in IT
so we don't do clean tech or healthcare
we've done a lot in the internet layer
companies like double-click we've done a
lot in enterprise software so companies
like versus systems and several in the
infrastructure space so companies like
riverbed and that's the gamut of what we
do my name is barb nevi I'm the CEO and
co-founder of Crockett which is a online
collaborative learning game actually our
first beta product out there is a GMAT
product which is a little bit late for
any of you folks but the idea is that
anyone preparing for the GMAT comes to
our platform and they collaborate live
on GMAT questions and there are game
mechanics that incent their behavior as
well as some sort of intelligent
algorithms that adapt system to your
performance and help you prove you're
you know GMAT test or SAT tests or
ultimately just generalized learning I
did a series a couple years ago and a
series B last year so that's the my
experience and
managing term sheets I've learned most
of what I know from venture hacks calm
if you want to check that out it's a
shameless plug for my brother's blog but
it is true it's not just him the ball
Rubicon's and a couple other cool folks
contribute to it but you know I did a
lot of learning before I did my first
one I had great advisors when I was
negotiating my term sheet in my series a
and in our Series B and those are I
think really important pieces that we
obviously can't really replicate here in
this session but a part of the larger
process of creating a temporary
marketplace for your shares it's not a
replacement for a really good lawyer
ideally from auric but I will second
adventure acts it's a it's a great place
to if you're trying to find a primer on
what to expect and and and what the
process is going to look like from a
from a real-world entrepreneurial
standpoint it's it's a it's a great
place to start
yeah I actually had excellent lawyers
too that were critical to the process so
yeah that goes with that thing but it
but it does help you kind of get into
the groove and and and understand the
dynamics of how it will work with it
because there will be plenty of times
when you're not going to be with your
lawyer going through term sheet
negotiating the deal and so the more
familiar you can get with the whole
process the better off you are and the
fewer times that you'll have to sort of
use a lifeline and call your lawyer Ken
to your term sheet or X Y Z's in term
sheet you want to start out and explain
why this is it was a good deal for fraud
in his company well Farb it's been a
pleasure getting to know you over the
past few months I like was really
excited about your your company and your
idea and I'm very much looking forward
to partnering with you so what I've put
together here is a standard term sheet
that that we've used at our firm and I
look forward to building the company
with you yeah we're actually really
looking forward to you know working with
you guys and I think with the right man
we've spent some time you know getting
to know our company and we've done our
diligence on your side and I think it's
going to be a real strong partnership
and you know there are just some pieces
of the this document that I've looked at
with my advisors and Council and I'd
like to just see if we can see a little
bit more eye-to-eye on some of the
pieces so I guess I can you know sort of
bring up mentioned some of my
non-starter because if you want to talk
like I talked about that or if they're
specific if you have questions about
anything I can explain everything that's
in the term sheet and you know what I
try to do is put together a term sheet
that will actually work for you I mean I
understand you know that having been in
your shoes as an entrepreneur before
building a company is hard so I'm trying
to put together something that works for
you
yeah that's great so a couple of things
we can I can sort of talk about them in
general and we can address them
individually or we can sort of address
them as we go or try to at least the
valuation is something that you know is
a sticking point for us we essentially
have a convertible debt that we have had
on the table for a while with some folks
some angels and I think we chatted about
this before and so for us you know there
is another option and if you know we
can't get the valuation that we're
looking for in a Series A we'll just do
the debt round and you know we'll work
on a series eight sometime next year or
when or when the time is right so I
guess you don't know if this is a
sticking point for you guys or there can
be some discussion around the valuation
because currently it doesn't make sense
for us and for me is you know acting on
behalf of all the shareholders right now
it doesn't make sense to go with this
when I have a convertible debt document
that I can do this you know about a
little bit less than half of the
investment but it'll get us through the
next you know 12 months and into product
launch and things like that so let me
stop for just saying just to clarify
what's going on
because I've got a competitive deal in
just in case if people are understanding
what is competitive deal is he's got
angels or somebody else who's willing to
do convertible debt so some sort of a
note that will convert into equity at a
future point at some later series a
financing at usually some discount to or
it's company buy warrants but at the
later valuation round later valuation
that's set by the series a round so
these guys will get into an argument
what that means and whether that's good
for farm and or council and if you guys
are interested in you know participating
in that debt round we can do that too
we'd love to have you guys on board that
way and you're obviously in it lined up
pretty nicely for when the series a
occurs but yeah like I said the
valuation currently is not competitive
with what we already have on the table
in terms of convertible debt yeah so I
think that that is definitely a viable
option from our perspective it all
depends how you want to build a company
you've you've done a lot of research on
us and you've called a lot of our
entrepreneurs and I think what they have
told you is that we work really hard in
terms of opening up doors at customers
and partners and helping you recruit the
VP level team that you're looking to
recruit and so you know given that what
we try to do is come up with a
evaluation that's you know as fair as we
could make it just based on all of the
deals that we're seeing and we think
that the amount of money that's going
into the company is a competitive
advantage for you because you're going
to be competing with other companies out
there that probably only have 500k or so
in seed or angel money and with two
million dollars in the bank you really
can press on the gas and take the market
by storm yeah that's you know obviously
we want to get to a couple million
dollars maybe two and a half in the in
the door it's really the the pre issue
valuation that is that is the problem
for us so the investment amount is right
we can get by with the 850 K debt round
that we're going to do
we're going to actually leave that note
open up to a million and a half so we
can continue to add to it we have about
750 to 850 committed and so it just
makes more sense for us to put that 12
months of runway out and then we can
drive a series evaluation that we feel
confident would be you know two three
four times what this is so if we can get
that done in 12 months and and have that
sort of impact on our actual series a
it's kind of a something we just have to
do so I guess if this is a non-starter
for you guys we can talk about some
other things and see we can come back to
it or if you want to you know they go
back into traffic folks and figure out
if you know how much of a deal-breaker
this is that's fine as well yes we we
discussed this at our partnership
meeting last Monday and the partners all
agreed on on these terms so I would need
to go back but just in round terms what
are you thinking about so we wanted to
actually bring in around two and a half
at about eight eight and a half post
okay so the six pre-write and how how
did you come up with that in terms of
comparables because what we try to do
here is since we see about 3,000 deals a
year and invest in about eight companies
yeah what we've tried to do is do what's
what's market and my guess countries
trying to make this term sheet look like
something that I would prefer over the
debt round that I have so that's how I
arrived with that number right sorry
there's a question
yeah so what
so go ahead the question was is what did
he mean by eight and a half million post
or six million pre-money so the the
valuation that's in the term sheet here
is a three million dollar pre-money
valuation and when you put two million
dollars into the company then the
post-money valuation is five million so
in this case the investors would get 40%
of the company or to two million over
five million what Farb just asked for is
a pre-money valuation of six million and
2.5 million investment so that would be
eight and a half million post so 2.5
million over the eight point five is the
percentage ownership for us twenty nine
percent which is twenty nine percent if
your people talk about two on a three
that's two million on a three month
during the three million valuation
can we stop yes we stopped so obviously
he's looked for an enormous pop up in
the in the pre-money valuation how often
and how successful generally our
entrepreneurs at asking a VC to go back
and and get a higher valuation I mean it
is it typically the case that on the
valuation instinct once it's gone
through the partners the first time
different firms work in different ways
so at opus would we put out a term sheet
we're done with all of our work and
we're ready to to sign the deal some
other firms put out term sheets and it's
kind of the start or maybe the start to
beginning of or middle of their process
so for us this this would have never
come up because during our process we
would have gone out to dinner probably
three times and we would have talked
about how he wants to build his company
how much money is required and we would
have talked we would have talked about
what's important to him but given that
this is a mock negotiation I'm trying to
ask yeah I'm totally in agreement you're
right this is not you know this the
laboratory this is the context the free
which is that most of this is agreed
upon before there's the actual piece of
paper saying we haven't dinner
conversations emails phone calls yep
what I can say is Farb is actually
working with me because based on the
numbers that he threw out there
the venture firm owns 29 percent in most
venture firms wanna own certainly above
20 percent for us we like to own you
know 25 percent plus because we're doing
this the series 8 rounds so while going
down from 40 percent ownership down to
29 percent ownership is a huge step down
I think having 40 percent is a bit
egregious you know quite I'm sure I've
seen legitimate real term sheets with
that you know the series any term sheets
so it's I think it's a great job but it
exists them I also agree that you know
the 25 to 30% area is reasonable for
standard for one VC if you have two VCS
in a deal forty percent is more standard
right yep
should we go back each VC will take 20
and the reason that's important from the
entrepreneurs perspective is if if a VC
has such little ownership then the VC
won't be as committed to your company so
they'd be much more passive
whereas what I told him before is that
we're going to work our butts off to
open up doors we're going to work really
hard to bring in a great management team
for him that's what I was you know
trying to get across there so you guys
want to defer on the valuation since
obviously this is good well I was going
to go one yes I okay okay so what I was
going to ask you barb is you know I
think that this ownership is is fair I'd
like to go back to my partnership with
something that's fair I appreciate the
the numbers that you've thrown out so
far I'm not sure how the partnership
will react to this or so can you give me
some sort of range that you feel
comfortable with that I go
to the partners I'd say you know to twos
the minimum you know two to
two-and-a-half is what we're looking to
do if you guys wanted to do over to Anna
that's fine and then probably no less
than seven seven and a half and if you
want me to come and push out yeah post
money and if you want me to come in and
chat with folks again I'm happy to do
that and or make them have some film
chats too so I appreciate you okay
taking that back up to folks by the way
the dynamic that was described about the
dinners and it's socializing it that's a
very Silicon Valley way of dealing with
whiffle term-sheet and provisions east
coast foreign investors it can be very
different and and you can have
situations where the first thing to know
about evaluation is when they throw the
term sheet down and then you really do
have these sorts of negotiations very
unusual lot here mark and it might be an
exploding term sheet which you know you
can explain in detail but it's basically
like act now or it's gone and I would
advise not dealing with people to give
you those sorts of tensions yeah I agree
with that and I think that every VC
should treat every entrepreneur equally
obviously if you've sold to companies in
the past you're going to get a more
friendly term sheet but you know at
least our philosophy is is treat the
entrepreneurs like we wanted to be
treated when we were entrepreneurs yeah
and usually most of them were their acts
that's actually legitimate I get that
feeling for most VCS that they're very
entrepreneur friendly although this is
going to this interaction is going to
make them seem really it's nasty I think
they're actually very much for her okay
so why don't we keep going great all
right so I think I heard you loud and
clear I'll go back to my partners with
what you said that you know you're
looking to raise somewhere between two
and two and a half million you could
potentially go higher than that and you
know bottom basement Fremont of
post-money valuation is seven to seven
and a half great awesome thanks I guess
I also want to chat a bit about the
founder
agreement so the couple things I want to
address is I'd like you know I've been
working pretty much full-time on this
project for a solid year now without you
know any real income you know skip
scraping through my savings and I'd
actually like you know that essentially
count towards my vesting schedule and
right now you have it such that my
founder shares will four years four year
starting from the you know point of
issuance which will be at the first
Accord meeting which is going to if we
close this going to be in two months
from now so not only did I not get that
first year I'm going to lose kinetics
two months as I'm killing myself trying
to close this deal so for me it would be
important to be able to get that year's
vesting and actually have the vesting
point start at what you know but we'll
set it you know date a year ago
approximately um well actually the way
that we listed this out here actually
works I think well for you so as we
discussed I have a great chief marketing
officer that you'd like to bring into
the company and she's you know almost
ready to join I think I can help you get
her over the finish line cool
she's very savvy as will be a lot of the
other VP level folks that you bring into
the company the first thing that she's
going to ask is you know what's what's
your investing schedule mr. founder
right and if it's unequal that that
really creates a very strange culture
and paradox inside of the company so
sure I actually wanted to put this
together so that you know I'm not I
understand yeah and I totally appreciate
that and you know I guess my feedback is
a little bit different from folks or you
know around the valley other you know
entrepreneurs that I've chatted with and
VCS and the you know I haven't heard
that as a reason that what I mostly
heard is that people understand the
founders often have slightly different
arrangements and I think the logic that
I explained to you I would explain to
the marketing director and I would
expect anyone to understand that and in
fact I would expect that marketing
person to get the same thing that they
started working with me last year
whether or not we even call them a
founder technically or not I would
totally agree that
should also have that years vesting but
you know they're starting actually if we
bring them on board they'd be starting
now so it's logical to have four years
so I think what I you know the way I'm
looking at it makes sense and you know
it's a pretty important point for me and
then the other issue would be something
celebrated vesting if I get terminated
because currently right now I would lose
we haven't gotten to the board yet which
is the next thing I'd like to talk about
but currently if I am removed from the
board sorry from the position of CEO and
the board I have you know I lose all my
chairs and actually if I if we also if
you put those two together I could you
know be fired in like a month or so and
then literally not have one single chair
in my company that I am working on for a
year so this is just creates a
opportunity that I need to have off the
table and confirm night talked about
this before your meeting and the I think
farm would be looking for some amount of
single trigger acceleration where if
he's determined if he's terminated
without cause he'll get some
acceleration and then full acceleration
on it on a double trigger if the company
is acquired and then he's terminated his
shares get fully accelerated okay yeah
so Bob I hear you loud and clear I still
think the way that this is worded works
best in your favor I mean the reason
that we're investing in this company is
because of you sure and your involvement
but if you were not involved in this
company Farb we would not be interested
in in working with you yeah like we
really need your involvement with the
with the company and you've committed to
that and so I think that that that's
great this you know really just puts it
on paper that when you're at the company
adding value to the company you're
you're vesting yeah I mean I guess I'm
just kind of I agreed I would more
strongly agree that that's the way you
felt if you remove that opportunity to
execute on this agreement off from the
table then I you know would be supremely
confident but that's
you sort of just said is really the sort
of type of relationship that you want to
create and you know my job is to have
you know work for the shareholders
increase the value of the company I
don't want to be thinking about you know
my board behaving in the Grievous ways
and like I said I just need that I
actually think it helps you guys because
if the option is completely removed from
the table you can't be pressured by
anyone to act on it because it's not an
option and so we have to just work
together as opposed to sort of remove
each other I can't really remove you but
this sort of allows that sort of in one
way control and that's sort of what
would be an issue for me I want a sort
of you know coexisting relationship here
where we're sort of incentive to work
together as opposed to the opportunity
in the door open for what I think is
sort of egregious behavior by either
party and I don't have any opportunity
for that and I think we should sort of
create a equally and so what what are
you recommending oh I guess um in in
terms of just one year with the US bank
so my shares will vest monthly starting
right now no cliff um they start vesting
right now because I've been working and
I'm going to continue working so they
start vesting monthly for the next three
years
136 per month starting the day of the
week create a company or functionally
it's it's the same as what you're asking
for but just giving him credit for the
year these work yeah for your vesting
which is totally standard but give them
credit for the time that exactly the
first year that I've spent working and
there's the cliff is like essentially
open as well and then you can give you
the details on the type of accelerator
so on the on the vesting side I hear you
loud and clear but if this company does
get into an acquisition mode obviously
the acquiring company is going to want
the the founding team there I mean
you're the heart and soul of this
company and that's where a lot of the
value comes from yeah so I guess you
know another issue is that you I we've
been working together on this deal a lot
and I you know I mean
in your participation on the board
specifically from from from the firm and
I have to deal with the reality that
there's no guarantee that you're always
going to be at that firm and so I don't
have a guarantee that you're always
going to be the board member I can think
of plenty of examples of great board
folks that were a VCS at one firm and
moved to another firm and they're not on
the boards of the startups that they
helped you know get off the ground and
that can be real you know shock for me
as a CEO and for our entire company so
to some extent I have to create
protections around just the possibility
of you not being there one day and
having some other person who have no
idea what their behavior is going to be
like relative to yours to deal with so
again it's a sort of a protection around
taking these opportunities to you know
play weird games off the table okay just
kind of concentrate on something
together and always important together
so I I hear you on the vesting schedule
so I'll let me think about that as
grown-ups yeah absolutely we're talking
about but let's talk about this
acceleration okay as single single
trigger acceleration which is that if he
gets fired from the company that he
accelerates his stock that's most work
that that is is very very difficult for
for us to do because basically that
would and sent sent you to potentially
just to get six months of vesting do
something bad so that we need to fire
you I guess I don't know what I can't
say what I say is the worst thing you
could do for this company so I don't
think it's doing anything for any of the
shares that I have at that point to fire
me that would so what I like if you
think that I would think that way I
wouldn't do business with me because
that's just you know I think an extreme
right but without a practical person
would engage it but that's the the
reason that single trigger is is
completely non-standard and if you look
at the NBC a documents it is it's not in
there now what you're asking for in
terms of double trigger acceleration
which means that if the company gets
acquired and your position in the new
company material changes
materially changes and you have some
sort of damina nation in terms of your
your type of role and the new company
then perhaps it makes sense that you
should get some acceleration because
that's something that neither you nor I
have any control sure that's up to the
acquiring company
oh so that's um you know so that I'm
going to think about that that's that
I'm I'm more comfortable with if it's
limited cool um the single trigger
acceleration I got to tell you we would
have a really hard so the one year
you're cool with and the mill cliff and
so on the on the vesting double trip I'm
the vesting schedule on the vesting
schedule what I recommend is that you I
think it's great that you worked at the
company for a year I was going to
suggest something shorter than that a
year so to split the difference but if
you're willing to vest over four years
after the investment then I'm willing to
give you a year a year up front yeah
that makes sense okay so we'll do one
year of credit and then you'll vest the
other 80% of your stock over the next
four years
yep okay 2075 no no no one one year
twenty five percent will be vested as
twenty twenty percent upfront and then
24/7 investing right exactly oh I see
what you're saying okay I'm going to
think about I'm going to put the thing
about that it's a little bit you know
probably won't be a sticking point but
yeah what you didn't realize is it
cancelled BMWs yeah you have a question
so a cliff is when you pass a certain
point in your vesting schedule that the
all of the the stock options that would
have vested up at that point become
vested so in this example the typical
for an employee in the valley is a
four-year vesting schedule with a
one-year cliff which means after the end
of year one that employee will get 25
percent of their stock options and then
the rest of those stock options the
other 75% vest over the next three years
on a monthly basis uh the I guess um
it's a three-person board which is good
like the odd number then one common one
preferred and one independent so there's
two issues I have one sort of a
non-starter one I guess I can want to
just chat a little bit more around in
the provision one board seat will be
elected by the holders of a majority
interest of the common stock and shall
be the CEO of the company I guess that's
kind of my issue what I'd rather do is
create an additional seat for a CEO so
because in this situation again it sort
of leaves the ifi'm about the CEO then
I'm not the common seat and I'm no
longer a director or CEO you know in the
company that I started so that doesn't
really make make sense and I would be
still the majority common shareholder so
I would be the majority shareholder of
the common stock but not be able to
elect the director of the common stock
because I wasn't the CEO and this is
Iike cording to this the CEO would have
to take that seat so that so far what
you're proposing is a three-man board
unless you're not the CEO in which case
it becomes a four-man board but yeah
change your seat I'm comfortable sort of
chatting about what we do post that if
it becomes a four-man board or maybe we
want to you know restructure the board
so that it's also still even and
bringing you know another independent on
or just you know we can play with those
numbers for sure but certainly so want
to get past the whether or not that's it
sort of non-starter for you guys is it
wouldn't be comfortable with this as it
is maybe if it was a you know we could
talk about situation words to common to
preferred and an independent will have a
five-person board and if one of those
common seats has to be the CEO I could
potentially deal with that but again it
still doesn't make sense to me you're
sort of taking rights away from we're
sort of taking rights away from
shareholders and really shareholders
should have the rights which are the
rights to elect directors of the board
so the majority of the shareholders
should the
for those board seats so really my
preference would be to create a new seat
for the CEO so that's kind of a stickler
for me and then the other let's do this
for them on the on the board we like you
think that small-bore boards perform a
lot better yeah we like the fact that
there's a three-person board
what would I suggest that we do is that
we leave the language here the same for
this for the common okay but should you
cease to be CEO for some reason or
another let's just say that that you
know you decide to go you know fly
airplanes or something like that true
then why don't we at that point in time
come to an agreement in terms of how to
make this a five-person board and we
could potentially add you as a board
member and then have the the preferred a
get another board seat as well so it
will go from three person to five person
yeah so you're saying let's not bake it
in right now and sort of address it if
and when it pushes you in whatever the
structure put in the language that it's
a three-person board okay that the
comment
shall have one board seat and that shall
be the CEO okay it is Farb and yet right
as far and if and then do it it isn't
and then should Farb cease to be CEO
then what I recommend is that we
increase the board to five people oh I
see and the common shall be Oh to vote
in that fourth board member and
preferred a will vote in the fifth board
member okay so yeah it's sort of like
what I was proposing is um yeah I guess
my only issue with that is that it still
is sort of um the taking away the rights
of the common shareholders to actually
vote based on their majority votes right
and place all come and I mean I think
well one should certainly be a CEO
because no let's just say that your bid
you want to go fly airplanes and we we
together as a group decide that we want
to recruit a CEO no no self-respecting
CEO is going to join a company without
being on the board sure you will get a
crappy CEO I can tell you that right
sure um I guess I would be you know
more comfortable going to a situation
then when it were it what you know like
let's just you know get rid of the
independent and a rather if that happens
we you know maybe we lose the
independent and then the CEO takes that
and there's two common and two preferred
and the CEO see I guess I just really
don't feel comfortable in a situation
where a certain class of stock cannot
just vote for their their you know but
that's not such a cheap number for forty
number for yeah so in the case that you
will not be a CEO it's the only one that
we'd get to vote on right correct well
the other one is CEO who is working at
your I guess Mohammed shareholder yeah
the CEO is technically a common
shareholder he's blowing smoke I'm not
on that point
yeah the CEOs the Convair holder but
it's a lot but I think it's pretty
likely that they're going to be pretty
investor leaning you know there's a lot
of issues with you know obviously we're
bringing in a new CEO that it may have
to do with an issue of my performance
and this means that you guys are heavily
you know picking that CEO and they're
just going to naturally be investor
leaning so I guess we just end up
creating a board where I'm you know one
one of four and again really have much
influence on on the company and I'm just
I don't think it's to the advantage of
the company for that to really be the
situation for at least them through the
series a series be maybe Series C at
some point certainly the company may be
served better by not having me as a CEO
or even on the board directors
potentially but I think that's a long
way away so me being on the board not
being having any ability to do anything
is essentially like me not being on the
board
okay so I should do much more what you
want to talk about what's common in this
situation yeah I mean uh and it's all
over the map here in terms of what you
wind up compromising with what what Ken
suggested is is getting towards where
it's typical and a lot of Series A deals
if it's if it's if it's a good series a
deal and it's a founder with a hot hand
then he'll often be able to
insist that he gets his seat you know he
gets he gets one and a lot of times
you'll see too common so farm had a
co-founder you see both co-founders on
the board and then the series a seat so
the common still controls the board and
they're they're a bunch of protective
provisions that give some protection to
the series a but the common controls the
board you tend not to see these issues
until you get into the into the later
rounds sometimes you will see four-man
boards for series eight companies where
you've got two founders and and two
preferred what what ken was proposing
was where you've got a four-man board
but Farb is only one there's only one
common holder the CEO a new CEO almost
always will be more tightly affiliated
with the investors than the existing
founder if a founders leaving at that
earliest stage things have gone badly
wrong and so the new CEO is going to be
vetted the other thing that that I'm
trying to protect against is not having
somebody that's dissident on the board
because if there's a founder that's just
trying to make trouble it's on the board
and they vote no when there's some board
votes it can make things really sticky
from a legal perspective like when
you're trying to sell the company and
that sort of thing so the way that I was
trying to do it is to make is to have
far be the number four person on the
board but have that be a language that
in the closing documents would be pretty
loose that would say something to the
effect of you know we will use our best
efforts to do X Y & Z so that if barb is
leaving the company we will negotiate
that as part of his severance package
yeah and I think that's what I was going
for what I stopped sort of doing after
the first discussion around the
valuation was going back and to my debt
convertible debt note that I had on the
table which I actually should have on
every single point to talk about how I
have an alternative especially here
because in you know doing a convertible
debt round there is no board created at
all and I control the company entirely
essentially
depending on the what we got the back
wage into and stuff so there is at least
there's no board and we can sort of put
off that decision to a series a so
really I should have just harped on that
a little bit more it's really I think
the most important thing for a founder
going into any negotiation is having you
know a best alternative should go back
to the liquidation preference I think
this is because it you know is that one
last thing on the on the board you'll
see that there's an independent board
seat here
there needs to be a mechanism in here so
that there's a way that that person gets
nominated and accepted to the board
because right now he could nominate
someone and I could say no I could
nominate someone you could say no and it
would be just a two-person board and
that would be ineffective series a will
receive prior and in preference any
payments of the holders of common stock
of per share amount equal to three times
the original purchase price of the
series they it seems you know my
preference would you know just be one X
but I'm willing to I guess split the
difference and say 2x and I assume that
this is a typo that it was 3x
yeah with full participation yeah for
the 3x initial yeah that's what I'm
assuming okay
sorry my no problem no problem state but
this is a participate participating
preferred which means that if we invest
two million dollars of our money into
the company and the company gets
acquired for 10 million dollars we get
six million dollars back first and then
we split up the remaining four million
on a pro-rata basis which is what we
described on yeah one it's not a cycle
you did intend to fully participate in
the news explaining the typo or no oh
good I wanted it as participating
preferred because boaters without a cap
because Farm is you and I discussed you
know we have so many companies that we
can potentially invest in we want to
invest in companies and entrepreneurs
that want to grow company to a very
large large rate sure and an outcome
because if this company just gets built
to say be acquired for five million
dollars it's not a great use of your
time or or our time sir this is the type
of mechanism that I think works well for
you because you you and I will be
motivated and it's a way to build a
large company here Kenan is going to
hurt you in the later rounds when when
the series being screw you see money
come in and say well well pretty long
there is well there's a Nokia the full
participation no cap you know it's one
thing if you're doing this at a 3 or 5
or 6 million dollar valuation but if you
start doing the next round at a 25 three
or forty three or higher and you've got
full participation not only as far I'm
going to get hammered but you're going
to get hammered even even if you're
you're taking your pro rata eventually
that will that will cut back you sure
you want to do this at this early stage
so but what I'm trying to put in place
here is something that incensed
everybody the same so for the later
rounds will will solve the later rounds
at at that later time I guess yeah I
mean you know I understanding is that's
almost impossible
oh why you know I guess put up such a
enormous task ahead of us and let's just
bacon something that will serve us both
now and serve us both now in the later
rounds be given that you wanted such a
big step up in terms of valuation well
what's more important to you the
valuation for the liquidation preference
um I'd have to think about that well I
think we'd be looking for a reasonable
market liquidation preference in this
day yeah isn't even on the aggressive
side of the market this is just
completely outside of what you would see
in a term sheet here so even if barb is
looking for something that's on the
higher end of market reasonable on
valuation you know it would be fair to
at least see something on the investor
friendly side of market fair okay so
what would you suggest for uh so you
know we're thinking maybe a 2 X on the
on the first part and social gaps yeah
and yeah basically yeah no participation
so no participation above the 2 X
correct right but a 1 X participation
below 2 X correct so they take me
through the map again if the company
gets bought for 10 million you guys put
in
with just let's say that we put in two
at at five post so I mean sorry you guys
either get four or you choose to convert
to common and then then you have a total
all of the common are treated equally
and you're just like every other every
other common holder but and so there's a
there's an economically rational point
at which you'll convert to common well I
get I get the two million back up front
because we're you know we're putting
this money to risk we we should be the
first ones to get our money back
sure so we do get that and then what
you're saying is we participate pro rata
after that point up to the point until
we get to X on our money but right okay
yeah so that that I would go for that's
pretty much standard see there 2x or 3x
yeah and I and I would even say it's
especially these days if ken got four
million back here you got you got his
money back and then an additional two
before anybody goes to common that's not
wouldn't be totally outrageous either so
the cab that that Farb is talking about
is at what point would it be better for
me to really convert to common and just
participate pro rata which is on which
is on page one and here's one of those
places where it's helpful to have the
lawyers involved because the arithmetic
is actually not arithmetic it's actually
math and and so you want to have
somebody who can help you model it out
and it's it's not obvious and it's
nonlinear particularly when you have
participating preferred the if you graph
it out it's just it's got steps through
it and so in in reality this rarely
comes into play you know what happens is
as a company gets purchased the
management team or the company is trying
to get purchased the management team
says if it's a if it's a downside
scenario listen we're going to just
leave this company here you can have it
or we want to carve out and so all these
liquidation preferences get renegotiated
at that time so I totally agree with
what you were saying which is why set a
precedent that the later round eyes can
rodolfo that is really good logic and
I'm sure Ken doesn't have any companies
doing down rounds right now that's where
we're seeing this come up a lot is when
companies are doing down rounds and new
money's coming in and trying to deal
with the existing the existing prefer
holders then you start really cranking
em all
you were really grumpy about the drag
along yeah
is that a drag along and by jus skipping
over a bunch of stuff in just in the
interest of time I guess my issue here
is that anyone in the event of any
proposed sale event on page 5 dragged
along rights where such transaction is
approved by the holders of a majority of
Series A Preferred and each member's
board directors the founders and all 1%
stockholders become and shall be
required to vote all capital stock in
favor of such transaction so essentially
it's the same one that we had it's
saying anyone that owns less than 1% of
the company just does what you guys tell
them to do and it's sort of like I think
people should just be able to vote their
shares and wherever the numbers sit they
sit you know there's going to be a lot
of serious stakeholders in the company
that are going to own less than 1% of it
like a lot of the founding team you
essentially were essentially removing
any influence they have on anything
their shareholders which already doesn't
make sense they built the company the
doubly doesn't make sense so let's just
strike the the issue is is that when
companies get acquired if there's
dissenting shareholders there can be all
sorts of lawsuits and things like that
so far you're a big honor in the company
you have 30% ownership in the company
why would you want to have some other
shareholders that aren't nearly as
involved is what you and I our control
our destiny and potentially get the
company into a bunch of liquidation
right in a bunch of litigation rather I
think it's a lot better to get make sure
that everyone's a mind and that's
exactly what the board is for and that's
why we negotiated the way we did on the
board and I think you're happy with how
you're being represented on the board
and you know I'm okay with it we owned
40% of the company
we only have one board seat so I mean I
think that we've been as far as we can
but I'm so Ken if what you're trying to
do is protect both yourself and far from
the smaller investors you know you're
assuming that the farm is going to be on
the board and is going to approve the
deal why don't we change this so that if
it's if it's approved by the holders of
majority of the series a each member of
the board and the founders how about a
majority of the board and I think that's
better because what yeah well but but if
the farm will only hold one seat then
what if if the concern is not far I mean
if they tell us if the concern is that
Farb isn't going to approve a deal then
we'll deal with that one way but if as
you said the concern is that other
investors might dissent and you're
you're not worried about far because you
guys you guys are completely like then
let's let's make sure that the drag
along can't be triggered without Farbs
consent well it's more that I think that
everybody should be under this straddle
on that everybody when the company is
sold that everybody's voted in the same
direction that'll make for an
expeditious process now the you know the
reason that we're investing this company
again is because of you Farb but let's
just say that you want to go fly
airplanes like we were talking about
before you know everybody's going to be
working with this company and the
company will have decided that it should
should get sold and if you are back
there throwing you know eggs just just
to be difficult that that I think is a
very unproductive process because I just
can't imagine this environment situation
where I'm going to about get cashed out
of this companies that I have all these
shares in that I even put in less work
because now I'm flying planes and I
don't some for some reason I'm going to
make trouble and not just get cash that
aren't you really concerned about a deal
where comment gets nothing
and and he checks to having a company
sold out from under him and he gets
nothing for it and that's the
Square your trip with the provision in
place so that he has to vote in favor of
the deal um yeah I mean propose a tinkle
a key setting patent you know not have
founders as the third point here right
and not include founders in the dragged
along portion the one-percenters I think
I can deal with it I think so the issue
I founders dragged if the founders
approve
yes that's what yeah that's a loot yeah
so what you know from my perspective for
this company to get acquired it's going
to be because of the founders and
there's no way that a company can get
acquired without you know the founder
and the rest of the team moving forward
so as long as you know you're committed
to working with us and in good cases and
bad to get the company sold at the right
time and at the right price you know I'm
I'm okay with that
okay great and yeah I mean all my you
know negotiating is around yeah and
something just to sort of have to work
together when we come up to situations
that aren't they don't have easy answers
so I'm totally so I will go through the
exact language here and in the closing
documents but I understand what you're
trying to get to this is a this is a
major major sticking point and I would
say that in like 75 percent of the term
sheets
there's drag along that's that's put in
there and and it's for good reason
unfortunately so I mean my experience
it's it a lot most startups have more
than one founder and I would say 95% of
and I'm kind of making up these numbers
but it rough broad strokes there right
95 percent of startups one of the
founders is gone in a year and so what
you worry about is not farm is going to
be there through the acquisition because
it really believes in the company's a
good guy he's a company man
you worry about the founder who's gone
so that's exactly what I was talking
about when I was talking about going to
the closing documents the closing
documents we'll talk about who a founder
is and how a founder is is defined and
so I would make sure that it would be a
fully employed person of the company so
anybody that's not employed by the
company you know can't throw charge at
the company later yeah and I mean like
you said in a lot of situations if you
have multiple founders obviously more
founders you have to start with the more
likely you are to lose one of them as
time goes and I think they would all
agree that it would you know that
provision makes sense that you have to
be employed at the company of the
founders sort of be a part of that I
don't think there'd be much division and
now all this being said can have you
ever actually seen this implemented
where where you had to pull the trigger
on the drag or is it all in my
experience is always sort of the sword
of Damocles that it's out there and
nobody nobody exactly event nobody will
actually require somebody to trigger
there's some question as to whether it's
totally enforceable right and legally
that's off the red button against a this
yeah it's bending upon the circumstances
I agree but it is very important that
when you do get into a sale process that
no one can hold it up so for example if
if a founder had left the company he may
want some hush money to vote to vote yes
you know that's something that we would
never allow right but I have you know I
have seen cases where they where that
happens it was interesting so you want
you know from an investor from an
investor's perspective you want
everybody doing what's in the best
interest of the shareholders and that's
why I drag is there yeah then we're
towards the end of the time so we'll
take some questions there's one other
point that I just wanted to highlight
because you talked about it and it
relates to the valuation and it's the
size of the option oh yes there's
another our it yeah it is because it's a
backdoor pricing negotiation because you
bake the size of the option pool into
the pre-money capitalisation
the company so if you if you have to if
you have a big option cool then you wind
up with a smaller price per share for a
given evaluation and so it's a way of it
backdoor negotiating or price from my
perspective I would want it would be
great if the entire option pool came out
of the post that never happens right
that's what I'm saying that's my extreme
this extreme is the entire thing coming
out of so to the degree that you can
move closer to what you would ideally
want data we Iskander to do with dudes
again the standard is is what's here
what's egregious is the percentage
okay so twenty twenty percent is high if
we have a CEO at the company and we're
not planning to do a CEO search and so
if you and I were negotiating on this
I'm sure what you would say is listen
all we need is a VP sales so that's two
percent VP Marketing that's two percent
and a director of engineering that's one
percent so all we need is five percent
yeah he actually gave the best I think
that's the best line of reasoning is you
actually went and did some comps and
figured out what the exact percentage is
for all the people you need to hire and
it's that number and then you have a
reason for why it's that number and it
may be five six seven eight yeah 10
percent now what standard is that
there's some slush on that sure like at
least four or five percent because you
want to bring in advisers you want this
option pool to last well into the series
B which should be at least twenty twenty
four months just in case something goes
wrong and you need to extend the series
a you might get a blue bird person that
could come in as a CLO and demand seven
percent and the last thing that you want
company to do is pass on really good
people because they don't have the
shares in the option pool I mean what I
would sell the company is it's a blue
bird and if it's a blue bird that is not
in the plan that was baked among the the
founders and the investors before the
financing then everybody ought to share
in that dilution that's that that's not
that shouldn't come in the back
founders you can always create more
shares there's nothing stopping it's
just yeah it's just one board action
away from magically more Oh was she fair
to superwoman
it's true but I'd say that the average
option pool in most Series a term sheets
that are this early stages is fifteen
percent yet